okay let's get serious people in the
past few years we have seen many
releases of new iphones that always had
impressive specs worth their heavy price
tags but this year it seems a bit
different according to the rumor mill
the new iphone 14 coming out later this
year will not be much better than its
sister the iphone 13. so in this video
i'll explain why i believe the new
iphone 14 might be a bad buy have we
reached the peak from the outset let me
clarify that some of the opinions
discussed in this video come from
loyalists who already own the latest
iphone 13 and will definitely buy the
next iteration despite its updated price
tag and others are coming from the
skeptics who are still on the fence so
my reasoning for this controversial
opinion is well balanced comparing the
new iphone 14 with the iphone x and xs
models there will obviously be
noticeable leaps in camera technology
and the processor speed but with apple
significantly slowing down its
improvements over the last couple of
years the question needs to be asked
have we reached the peak for the iphones
it's a well-known fact that smartphones
are getting better and better with time
every year brings with it new
innovations processing power more memory
more software intelligence higher
resolution and other advanced features
even cheaper smartphones have high-end
features that were previously only
reserved for much more expensive phones
like the iphone this is the reason why
the world of smartphones is getting more
and more competitive the last decade saw
significant innovations in the iphone
including the first selfie camera the
first 3d touchscreen and even security
features such as face id but now we are
only getting incremental progress as
technology slowly reaches a zenith
progress will only slow down even
further apple didn't mention the iphone
14 during this week's wwdc 2022 event
although this is hardly surprising given
the company's standard refusal to
discuss any product it hasn't announced
but according to well-established
industry sources the difference in
specifications between the iphone 13 and
the 14 will be minimal there are some
talks of a significant increase in
camera technology which i will explore
later in the video but other than that
there will only be a few other minor
changes and mostly superficial so the
new iphone 14 won't be too much of a
technological leap from the older
versions obviously there will be some
updates to the chipset apple will likely
release the new iphone 14 pro model with
the new a16 processor still the standard
14 and 14 max models will most likely
retain a variant of the older a15
processes so have we reached the peak
with the iphone no i believe we haven't
reached the peak yet of course not
technology is still steadily improving
and much scope is still remaining but we
are coming pretty damn close to it the
older iphone models like 12 or 13 are
pretty impressive machines and will
still be able to perform most of their
functions for years to come that being
said the next question that needs to be
asked is whether you should upgrade to
the new iphone 14 and will it justify
the increased price tag is it worth the
extra money how do i know the new iphone
will cost more in case you missed this
week's wwdc 2022 event it was unveiled
that the new macbook air powered by the
company's new apple m2 processor will
sell at a 200 premium over what the
macbook air m1 sells for this coupled
with the fact that there is a global
shortage of semiconductors and the
overall prices of components have
skyrocketed in the last year so you can
be sure that the iphone 14's base price
will increase by at least 100 if not
more so will the iphone 14 be worth the
extra money to be honest i don't think
so unless the primary purpose of your
iphone purchase is to click pictures and
record 8k videos let me explain the
iphone 13 series came out with many
differentiating factors for example the
13's pro model came with an extra
telephoto camera lidar pro motion
display stainless steel frame higher
storage additional ram and other minor
upgrades these upgrades were enough to
convince people to spend that extra
money and get it however this year
rumors say that the iphone 14 will be a
slightly better version of the previous
iphone the biggest one is definitely the
higher 48 megapixel camera in the pro
version apple has always stuck to its
guns and never increased its camera's
megapixels from 12 even though the rest
of the market competitors have
experimented with insane numbers such as
108 megapixels so did apple finally do
this because it ran out of other
improvements to make in its new iphone
14 pro i believe it could very well be
the case however it has to be said that
increasing the megapixel count doesn't
necessarily mean better quality of
pictures and videos a lot depends on the
overall processing power of the system
but this change will finally allow
iphones to capture 8k video which
samsung phones have already had from a
couple of years ago i also believe that
given the iphone's superior
post-processing software capabilities it
will undoubtedly do a better job than
samsung but how significant is an
upgrade like that for its regular users
especially since the iphone 13's camera
is not just great but class leading
despite only having 12 megapixels the
other major upgrade is cosmetic in
nature with the iphone 14 it seems that
apple has finally decided to remove the
notch and replace it with a circle and a
pill-shaped design to house the dot
projector and the front camera this will
undoubtedly increase the dimensions of
the overall screen area but then again
it is nothing we haven't seen before in
other phones the pill shape was
introduced by the huawei p50 last year
and apple is now reduced to copying the
design as it is perhaps the most
efficient way of placing the front
camera while maximizing the screen area
so far the upgrades don't seem
convincing enough to demand the extra
100 increase in the base price as i
already mentioned the processor will
only get an upgrade on the pro version
so the standard iphone 14 will be
sharing the same processor as the 13.
can you imagine even with a full year
difference between the 13 and 14 we get
to see the regular 14 models with the
same a15 chip now that really shows how
slow apple's improvements in the iphone
are getting each year i mean with the
pedigree of achievements that this
company boasts of this is getting
somewhat embarrassing so from my point
of view the iphone 13 will still be
equally powerful as the iphone 14 base
models with its a15 bionic apple finally
fixed the perennial battery drainage
issue so i can fully enjoy my iphone for
more extended periods it's also powerful
enough to run most of the modern apps i
throw at it and will probably serve me
well for a few more years to come so if
you ask me i can't justify the extra
price that apple will most certainly tag
on when it releases the iphone 14 lineup
later this year in october some might
say i'll compromise on the better camera
and the new notch design that's why i
mentioned earlier that if your goal is
to shoot 8k resolution videos with your
new iphone by all means you should go
for the upgrade but if that's not your
priority then the iphone 13 does a hell
of a job with its exciting specs and you
probably won't miss the new iphone 14 in
your day-to-day usage other speculations
there are a few more speculations about
the new iphone 14 lineup that can't be
discounted offhand for example some
sources say that the phones will likely
get bigger than the previous lineup this
is not a bad upgrade for people who like
bigger phones bigger phones certainly
have advantages and i believe apple
would be wise to fully use them industry
rumors also claim that the new iphone 14
will feature more memory and 6e wifi
connectivity now this is definitely good
news more memory is always welcome and
6e wi-fi connectivity is the upcoming
standard that enables a smoother
browsing experience by delivering four
times higher bandwidth and 75 percent
lower latency the only drawback i see is
that you'll need a 6e wi-fi enabled
router to get the most out of this
feature and these routers can be
expensive since you're already spending
a lot more on your new iphone 14 would
you want to spend more on a router maybe
apple can start selling their own 6e
wi-fi enabled routers and knowing apple
they probably will oh and one more thing
finally let me also mention that i
didn't speak of the software side of
things in this video since the software
updates can be used equally in the older
models as well so i believe that wasn't
required for the topic of this video
anyways apple will always find a way to
justify their new iphone releases and
charge extra money for them it's up to
the individual customers like us to
decide if we should reward such actions
and this year i don't find any
compelling reason why apple should be
charging more for its new iphone 14s
that's why i think the iphone 14 will be
a bad buy do you agree with my analysis
either way let me know in the comment
section below and show the channel some
love by subscribing and hitting that
like button see you in the next one